a boy named Prince Tomino runs through a
dark wood pursued by a dragon
just as it rears up to devour him three
mysterious ladies appear and slay the
dragon with their fierce battle cry so
begins Wolfgang Amadeus Mozart's dete
Salva flirty or the Magic Flute this
fantasy Zing's feel a type of folk opera
with music and dialogue premiered in
1791 in Vienna
though it may seem like a childish fairy
tale this intricate opera is full of
subversive symbolism and it's now
regarded as one of the most influential
operas in history Tomino is run-in with
the dragon is only the start of his
journey the three women summon their
leader the queen of the night she in
turn sends Tomino on a quest to rescue
her daughter
kameena from the evil sorcerer Zoroaster
oh and to help him on his journey she
gives him the titular Magic Flute Tomino
eventually finds Pamina at Czarist rose
temple but behind enemy lines Tomino and
Pamina learned that they're on the wrong
side the queen of night actually wants
to plunge the world into darkness
everything Tomino thought he knew was
wrong
filling him with doubt and confusion so
a new quest begins for Tomino and Pamina
they must pass three trials of wisdom
and only then can the day vanquish the
night helped by the flutes magic power
the two youths overcome these trials and
the Queen's attempts to sabotage them
they're finally initiated into the
temple having restored balance to the
kingdom many elements in this peculiar
fairy tale were inspired by Mozart's
involvement in Freemasonry a network of
fraternal organizations throughout
Europe much of their history symbolism
and ritual came from the Middle Ages but
the Freemasons of Mozart's time were
also influenced by 18th century European
ideal
rationalism humanism and skepticism
towards traditional authorities like
monarchy and the church the symbols of
Freemasonry and these ideals of the
Enlightenment are found throughout the
Opera if this sounds like a conspiracy
theory that's because it sort of was at
the time but it's now taken quite
seriously and has been the subject of
considerable scholarly publication for
example some Mozart scholars believe the
Queen of the Night
symbolizes Maria Teresa the Empress of
the Holy Roman Empire who opposed
Freemasonry and banned it in Austria
while there continues to be debate as to
the specific meaning interpretation and
location of these Masonic references
scholars agree that they're there and
are fully intentional one of these
symbols is the number three which
represented balance and order to
freemasons now the number three is of
course easy to find in any work of
storytelling but it's particularly
prominent in the Magic Flute three
trials three ladies three spirits and
three doors much of the music is written
in a flat major which has three flats in
its key signature and historically
Masonic rituals began with three knocks
the Opera references them by opening
with three majestic chords complete with
dramatic pauses those chords which
reoccur throughout the Opera serve
another purpose they capture the
dramatic arc of the Opera in miniature
the first chord E flat major is in its
most natural root position simple and
unadorned it echos the childlike prince
Tomino who in his naivete accepts
everything the Queen and her ladies say
without question the second chord is C
minor a sour sonority that mirrors Timmy
knows sadness and doubt in the middle of
the Opera that's when his world and
notions of good and evil
get turned on their heads and good and
evil are just two of the operas extreme
opposites it features some of the
highest and lowest notes in Opera
day and night simple hummable melodies
and complicated forward-looking music
the operas central theme concerns
balancing these extremes to achieve
perfect harmony to reflect this the
final chord in the opening restores
musical order it returns to the
triumphant be flat major the same chord
it started with but inverted meaning
Mozart moved the bottom note to the top
although it retains its original harmony
the chord sounds higher pointing towards
enlightenment that's similar to Tomino
who in passing his trials restores
balance to the kingdom while growing
stronger wiser and more complete
you